اين اديتياف اين برونو مارس ولماذا سيلين
ديون خارج التصنيف اعتراضات بالجمله على
غياب رموز فنيه عملاقه في قائمه افضل 200
مطرب عبر التاريخ والتي اصدرتها المجله
الامريكيه روليكستون لعل ابرز ما فيها ان
كوكب الشرق ام كلثوم حللت في المرتبه
الحاديه والستين ونقول 61 فقط عالميا
اعترض كثيرون على ترتيب مطربين بعينهم
لماذا مايكل جاكسون مثلا ملك البوب في
المركز السادس والثمانيه
وعبر تويتر شارك كثيرا من العرب في انتقاد
القائمه لا تمثيل عربيا في القائمه
باستثناء ام كلثوم لكن ترتيبها المتاخر
كان مطار التساؤلات كيف يعقل ان تكون كوكب
الشرق في المرتبه الحاديه والستين وعلى اي
اساس يمكن ان تتقدم عليها ليدي جاجا مثلا
اما جرت القمر فيروز غابت تماما عن
القائمه غاب صوت العرب محمد عبده ولم يذكر
اسم عبد الحليم حافظ العندليب الاسمر يزيد
من التفاصيل على كل حال سنطلع لكم عليها
ما قالت رولينكستون تقول ان قائمتها لافضل
200 مطرب عبر كل العصور ليست اختيارات
لاعظم الاصوات وعندما يستند هذا الاختيار
على درجه تاثيرهم في العالم
موسيقي اليكم بعض الاسماء البارزه في هذا
التصنيف ام كلثوم كوكب الشرق وايقونه
الطرب العربي في المركز 61
يصفها المقال بانها لا يوجد مثيل لها في
الغرب
مثلت روح العالم العربي لعقود ولا تزال
تمثل حتى الان الى حد ما فرانك سنترا صاحب
رائعه فلايميت دامون ولديه رحل عام
1998 جاء في المركز التاسع عشر وصف بانه
كان عملاقا وراء الميكروفون وفاز بكل
الجوائز الممكنه في عهده
والى الترتيب وتنهيوستن احد اساطير موسيقى
الانبياء في المرتبه الثانيه ولا تزال
اغنياتها ضمن الاكثر استماعا حتى بعد
رحيلها باحدى عشر عاما رغم كل الانتقادات
لكن هناك اتفاقا على احقيه المغنيه
والشاعر الامريكيه الراحله ريثا فرانكلين
لصداره القائمه ملكه موسيقى السلط توصف
بانها اروع صوت خرج من الولايات المتحده
وسبب رغبه النساء في الغناء سالنا الناس
من بيروت ومصر من اعظم فنان في التاريخ من
خارج بلاكم
جورج وسوف ام كلثوم
وعبد الوهاب وفريد هولي كانوا مطربين
بتسلى الوقت هي سوري عبد الوهاب ورده
الجزائريه
[موسيقى]
اعظم فنان في التاريخ يا فنانه
في التاريخ
علشان طريقه الفراخ بتاعته مختلفه
مغنيه عشان هي
عملت للبنات
نادين بالنسبه لك انت من اعظم فنان في
التاريخ يعني اذا من خارج بلادنا وخارج
منطقتنا العربيه
الايطالي جميل
صباح الخير
طبعا احنا يعني اول ما شفت الخبر انه
اختياره ام كلثوم ضمن افضل 200 مطرب او
مطربه في العالم
الخبر في حد ذاته خبر سعيد بالنسبه لي لكن
سريعا ما ااا
قعدت افكر لما شفت الترتيب وان هي رقمها
61 وسط الاعظم حسيت شويه انه الموضوع لا
في بعض
في بعض الظن شويه لتاريخها والمشروعها
خاصه انه حيثيات اختيارها او اختيار ال
200 مطرب كانت قائمه على فكره التاثير
العميق للفنان في و- ومشواره التاريخ ولو
حسبنا كويس هنلاقي انه من اعظم المشروعات
ال- همم الغنائيه والموسيقيه في همم في
التاريخ العربي كله
وهمم ومن اعظمهم في العالم طبعا المشروع
الفني لام كلثوم يعني
المراه التي تربت على عرش غناء لاكثر من
50 سنه من حياتها همم منذ العشرينات وحتى
يعني حتى راحلها سنه 75 وهي
الاكثر شهره والاكثر تاثيرا في المشروع
الغنائي العربي فكان من ال- اا من الافضل
يعني ومن المفترض انه ما يكونش فيه بعض
التحيز للامر يعني بانه ام كلثوم تكون في
مكانه متقدمه شويه يعني كده طيب
هذا هذه القائمه وهذا المقال اعتبروا ان
هذا التصنيفات هي مرتبطه بافضل المطربين
وليس بافضل الاصوات الثالث انه في ناس
ظلمه
اليه الترتيب يعني هل هو مساحه الصوت
مثلا جورج مايكل يعني كمان
بدنا نعرف شو وحده المعايير انه بناءا على
شو تم ترتيب المغنين بالطريقه اللي ركبوها
العظمه الصوت ولكن تاثير هؤلاء المطربين
عالميا
بالمرتبه الاولى الثالثه
[موسيقى]
عبد الحليم حافظ
طبعا يعني احنا بنتكلم عن سليم ديون واحده
من اعظم الاصوات لو احنا هنتكلم على
الاصوات هم قالوا ان هم بيختاروا على
المشروع مش على الصوت وطبعا ظلم ان سيلين
ديون ما تبقاش موجوده في ترتيب زي ده ظلم
جدا انه مايكل جاكسون يعني اهم موسيقي
تقريبا صاحب مشروع وغير من شكل البوب
ميوزك في العالم كله خلال ال 40 سنه اللي
فاته وكل نقاط العالم اجتمعوا على ده ما
يصحش خالص انه يكون الترتيب بتاعه متاخر
كده بهذا الشكل لو بنتكلم عن المشروع
الغنائي فبرده عدم وجود عبد الحليم حافظ
كارثه كبيره جدا في في في في استفتاء زي
ده او في اختيارات زي دي عدم وجود السيده
فيروز وان طارت همم يعني عننا وحرمتنا
منها اخر كم سنه لكن لكن السيده فيروز هي
المشروع الغنائي الاهم والاقوى العربيه
همم بعد مشروع السيده ام كلثوم يعني فبرده
عدم وجودها شيء همم مخرج جدا بالنسبه
للقائمه عبد الحليم حافظ همم مطرب عامر
للاجيال يعني مجدد في شكل الاغنيه من هو
اللي استلم الرايه من جيل ام كلثوم وعبد
الوهاب وسلمها للاجيال القادمه يعني لولا
عبد الحليم ما غنى بقيه الاجيال القادمه
فمشروع عبد الحليم حافظ كان مشروع يستحق
بقوه وجداره التواجد في همم في قايمه زي
دي وطبعا كثير من الاسماء زي ما قلنا
مايكل جاكسون يعني ترتيبه متاخر سنين ديون
مش موجوده ودي علامه استفهام كبيره جدا
على القائمه بصراحه يعني انطلاقا من كل
هذه المعطيات وصاروا الناس يعتبروا انها
القائمه مشكوك فيها وتحمل كثير من تساؤلات
في معايير معينه في المستقبل القريب وربما
يكون في زي قائمه مضاده لها
اكثر ليش تم انتقاء مغنيه او مغني مقابل
حدا ثاني مثلا بعرف بامريكا حاله سويلين
ديون مع انها محبوبي بس يمكن لانه ما انا
من امريكا يمكن لعب دور يعني يعني يمكن
الموضوع مسيس نوعا ما يعني كثير بحمله
كمان في اسامي يعني معظمنا ما بنعرفهم انه
ليش نقيته الاسم ترتيبه بالطريقه يعني
كبير كبير
على الموسيقى الحديثه والنجوم
هو ده برده كان اللي حضرتك بتقوليه ده كان
يعني بالنسبه لي مطار جدل احنا هل احنا
شويه ركزنا على الموجودين دلوقتي فالدينا
لهم حقهم يعني اديل ممكن تبقى موجوده
ومتقدمه بس ما اعتقدش ان هي تبقى يعني
متقدمه على كل الاسماء التاليه لها خاصه
ان انا لاحظت حاجه ان التوب تن تقريبا
منهم يعني في مجموعه كبيره من التوب 10
يعني مطربين امريكان وهي المجله الامريكيه
يعني مع الانفال بقيت همم عدد كبير جدا من
المطربين يعني انا وانا قاعد بتابع
القايمه طول الوقت انا باستفسر طب هو ليه
ده اتحط هنا وليه ده اتاخر في مطربين ممكن
ما يكونش انا اعرفهم ولقيتهم في في مرتبه
متقدمه اذا احنا قدام همم
حاله كان ينبغي لنا ان نبقى عارفين بس هو
تم الاختيار بناء
الحيسيات الاختيار اللي هم كاتبينها انه
التاثير والمشروع عمق التاثير الموسيقي هو
مشروع الموسيقي للفنان وليس الصوت تفضل
طيب احنا مش عارفين برده هل هل القايمه دي
هي القائمه النهائيه اللي ممكن تكون هل
نعتمد القايمه دي طول ال 50 سنه اللي
جايين ولا ممكن حد مجله ثانيه تطلع بقائمه
ثانيه فيها اسماء مختلفه عن دي فا نحس انه
في همم انه دي ما كانتش مضبوطه يعني احنا
لسه قدام قدام حاله همم يعني اتواجدت بس
من امبارح يعني لسه مش بقى لها كثير مش
عارفين نتايجها هتبقى تاثيرها ايه بس
الايام اللي جايه طيب في الايام الحديث عن
الايام الجايه هل في العقد المقبل ستتغير
هذه القوائم وتصبح تواكب جيل اليوم
وتطلعاته وماذا يريد ان يسمع ام سيضل
العريق القديم هو الاساس
قد تبقى لانه في كثير هلا حاله
من اول وجديد
عم يشتغل صح لازم تدخل اسماء جديده لانه
يعني هو بناء على ما يقبل له الجمهور هذا
المفروض
العصر كمان شكرا جزيلا لكم محمود فوزي
وشكرا من دبي هنا في الاستديو كنت معانا
المنتج والموزعه الموسيقي الزنقه شكرا لكم
شكرا لكم